die Lage könnte nicht dramatischer sein
wir haben in den letzten 40 Jahren
allein in Europa
600 Millionen Vögel verloren gute
Nachricht ist dass wenn wir die Fläche
von allen Gärten in Deutschland
zusammenrechnen dass diese Fläche
genauso groß ist wie alle
Naturschutzgebiete und Nationalparks
Deutschlands zusammen das bedeutet dass
wir eine enorme Power haben um den
Vögeln unter die Flügel zu greifen und
wirklich was zu bewegen und wenn jeder
in Deutschland der einen Garten hat auch
nur eine kleine Sache für die Vögel
umsetzt und das ist wirklich nicht
schwer dann können wir so viel bewegen
das würde den richtigen Unterschied
machen deswegen kommen hier drei ganz
konkrete Tipps wie ihr den Vögeln in
eurem Garten weiterhelfen könnt ein
riesengroßer Grund für das Vogel sterben
ist dass die kleinen Piepmätze einfach
kein Dach mehr über den Kopf finden um
ihre Kleinen auszubrüten deswegen ist es
so wichtig dass wir Nistkästen auf und
hier kommen ein paar Tipps was man dabei
beachten sollte Katzen sind natürlich
ein großes Problem ne die versuchen dann
immer die Kleinen da weg zu snacken
deswegen ist es total wichtig dass ihr
die mindestens zwei Meter hoch aufhängt
besser drei Meter einfach so hoch wie es
irgendwie geht wir haben hier auf dem
Hof den ich gekauft habe Nistkästen
aufgehängt hier gibt's zum Glück auch
schon jede Menge aber da geht immer noch
ein bisschen mehr und wahrscheinlich
kennt ihr alle diese klassischen
meisenkästen die sind natürlich auch
super aber was viele Leute vergessen ist
dass es auch für die gibt die diese
halbhüllen ist Kästen brauchen es gibt
ganz unterschiedliche Nistkästen für die
ganz unterschiedlichen Vogelarten
deswegen schaut mal ob ihr da vielleicht
so ein bisschen Abwechslung reinbringt
natürlich ist ein Meisenkasten auch
super aber die hier sind z.B für
Rotkehlchen geeignet und die soll
natürlich auch ein Zuhause bei uns im
Garten finden das Flugloch sollte immer
nach Osten oder Südosten ausgerichtet
sein und wenn ihr die Nistkästen in den
Baum aufhängt dann nehmt am besten hallo
Nägel weil die den Baum nicht schaden
oder einen Drahtbügel mit dem man die
auch ganz gut festmachen kann und im
Winter ist dann die perfekte Zeit um die
Nistkästen einmal sauber zu machen dann
packt ihr einfach das alte Nest raus
macht es wieder zu einfach damit sich da
nicht Krankheiten und Schädlinge in dem
Nistkasten verbreiten und das ganze
schön frisch ist und wieder viel Platz
ist wenn die Vögel im Frühling mit dem
Nestbau beginnen jetzt haben wir also
schon mal für die gemütlichen vier Wände
gesorgt aber die Vögel sind eigentlich
ziemlich ähnlich wie wir es gibt noch
eine andere große ganz wichtige Sache im
Leben das ist natürlich das Essen am
Anfang war ich mir was das Füttern
angeht irgendwie so unsicher weil ich
immer so unterschiedliche Sachen gehört
habe meint ihr Leute sagen man darf sie
im Sommer auf keinen Fall füttern und
nur im Winter andere sagen das ist total
wichtig dass man sie ganzjährig füttert
nachdem was ich jetzt gelesen habe
füttere ich meine Vögel das ganze Jahr
über weil das Insekten sterben
mittlerweile einfach so schlimm ist dass
die Vögel auch auch in den Sommermonaten
Schwierigkeiten haben ihr Futter zu
finden es ist nur wichtig dass man eben
im Sommer dann anders füttert da gibt es
dann spezialis sommervogelfutter da also
dann eine andere Mischung füttern als im
Winter im Winter sind Meisenknödeln
richtig tolles Futter da aber darauf
achten dass man nicht die mit dem Netz
nimmt weil die Vögel sich da drin
verfangen können ansonsten sind
Sonnenblumenkerne auch ein richtig gutes
basisfutter weil die von fast allen
Arten richtig gerne weggeknackt werden
wenn im Frühling dann die kleinen
Vogelbabys schlüpfen dann sollte man
aber mit den meisten Knödeln aufhören
und lieber einen anderes Körnerfutter
füttern weil ähm Meisenknödel eben nicht
gut sind für die Kleinen Vogelbabys im
Sommer schwenkt man dann eben um auf
eine sommervogelfutter Mischung und auch
beim Füttern ist es super wichtig dass
wir darauf achten dass die Vögel nicht
von Katzen gefressen werden können
deswegen einfach immer so hängende
Futterspender verwenden oder welche die
auf einem Stab sind da aber auch
vorsichtig sein die Katzen können ja
auch teilweise hochklettern
kann man am besten so aufstellen dass
die Vögel die Katzen schon von weitem
sehen falls sich eine anschleichen
sollte und dann gibt es ja ganz
unterschiedliche Futterspender für Vögel
und diese hier sind zum Beispiel gar
nicht so gut geeignet weil hier können
die Vögel einfach hinkommen setzen sich
mitten ins Futter und dann machen die
natürlich auch ihr Häufchen mitten ins
Futter und so können sich Krankheiten
unter den Vögeln richtig schnell
ausbreiten deswegen verwendet
stattdessen besser diese Silo
vogelfutterbehälter wo die Vögel außen
sitzen und am Futter fressen können aber
wo der Po nie über dem Futter ist wenn
ihr so eine in Anführungszeichen
falsches Futterhaus habt und das weiter
verwenden möchtet dann solltet ihr das
zumindest regelmäßig mit heißem Wasser
sauber machen damit es den Vögeln auch
weiterhin gut geht und der dritte Tipp
ist mein lieblingstipp hört auf eure
Fenster zu putzen das ist wirklich das
Beste was man machen kann um Vögel davon
abzuhalten gegen die Fensterscheiben zu
krachen das hat bestimmt jeder von euch
schon mal erlebt oder das ist so traurig
wenn man den Vogel dann da unten liegen
sieht und das lässt sich einfach
vermeiden wenn man die Fenster putzen
möchte mit Stickern die man in die
Fenster klebt oder Fensterschmuck den
man aufhängt oder eben dadurch dass man
das Fenster putzen einfach bleiben lässt
damit die Fenster nicht mehr so doll
Spiegeln und die Vögel erkennen dass
deine Barriere ist auf die Sie zu
fliegen ich glaube nicht dass ich euch
jemals darum gebeten habe eins meiner
Videos zu teilen aber heute ist es
soweit bitte teilt dieses Video wo auch
immer ihr aktiv seid im Internet schickt
das an Freunde die einen Garten haben
weil wir einfach wirklich einen
Unterschied machen können und dieses
Video ist auch Teil einer richtig tollen
Aktion die heißt save the birds die hat
der liebe Quentin vom Kanal bis dies ins
Leben gerufen ich kenne den schon sehr
lange von tiktok der Macht der richtig
tolle Videos zum Atem Sterben der
kümmert sich auch ganz toll um die
Bienen da machen auch ganz viele andere
Leute mit und hoffentlich jetzt auch du
also wenn du jetzt raus gehst und voll
motiviert mistkästen aufhängst oder
anfängst die Vögel zu füttern deine
Fenster nicht mehr putzt dann ähm
täglich gerne auf Instagram wir sind
nämlich jetzt neuerdings seit ungefähr
einem Monat auch auf Instagram und ich
würde mich total freuen wenn ich davon
euren vogelschutzmaßnahmen mitbekomme
also raus mit euch in den Garten und
rette die Vögel und wir sehen uns
nächste Woche wieder für ein neues Video
macht's gut tschüss